hi guys I'm Greg don't Aguirre and
injustice has occurred today I am moving
so it might not upload for the next
couple days Tony my friend who actually
introduced me to injustice Lucas here
with me and we're excited for injustice
to one of our last reactions while I'm
here at this apartment my last day here
I'm sad this is okay a couple of promos
here Tony
will eventually have a gaming channel up
working progress always working on it
Briana why who's come on the channel
several times has a channel called
strange rebel gaming almost that 50k
subscribers so check out her channel I
really would like you guys out for a I'm
a very melancholy sympathetic mood today
anyway everybody out injustice - here
comes the girls girls will be coming all
over the screen oh yeah alright
poison ivy sex Cheeta
who's that hard rock Gary
my claws will cut me down oh hey we're
done with crime how else can a girl get
your attention
exactly surprised to see me happy
Oh
now Oh
[Music]
one thing all right whoa gosh you know
wait yeah all right man so we got
Catwoman and they're Catwoman's in the
first one though hmm and then we got
poison ivy and poison ivy and she was
trying to do that man
sexiest villain they're just going like
oh yeah we're gonna try to make this
look and scantily-clad it is girls
looking but making it a spider they get
half naked and tie clothes and take off
guys who are super armed do us why I
haven't really seen them put too much on
that the suit suit they showed in like
the first one that we watched I wonder
if they're just like it's kind of just
like a bonus thing yeah it doesn't seem
like they're all like this let's keep
pushing the super suit yeah I think so
that's a good point but the girls here
are a great it didn't mean this is kind
of funny how with Gotham City sirens
being announced that they're going to be
doing this all female villains and DC
movies and then they have this coming
out now the trailer promoting all the
girls am i boom oh I think like
something cheetah black an area gonna be
in there it's getting even more entry
now I just love how they all look I know
cheetah can take on Wonder Woman I don't
know much about cheetah but I know she
can go toe to toe with Wonder Woman
that's for sure and then nothing about
to you if you a strong [ __ ] looks like
a cheetah and poison ivy they look like
they're hiking her up to do have some
badass powers we share but uh so they
just make you go like um question if you
want to this video yeah there's gonna be
some type of pornhub thing up these
girls for sure they're gonna create no
amount of animation with these designs
map it's always gonna be like well yeah
there's fighting in this but when do
they start boning yeah I go to porno is
Catwoman black again
I can't tell she's like light-skinned
black or she's wide and I star
town at the light tone looks like a
light-skinned black girl does look like
that doesn't look white to me in the
face I like the light-skinned black I
like dark I like any kind of black
really if you want to go to the Halle
Berry face on there yes like like one
your dog has been hyped up for so long
now I'm just excited to see like a lot
of the moves you could be a for things
like they're showing a couple of the
like x-rays moves poison ivy and
Catwoman have always been famous Black
Canary was always with known character
but I feel like ever since arrow she's
becoming like way more popular cheetahs
like sir there's a one for the comic
fans you know like that's all over I
don't think a lot of people are aware of
who cheetah is exactly and to give room
as much hype in this it's just like if
you're really into the comic and know
why you like this character so much but
Amelie as Batman and Nightwing yeah
flash in it and I think Green Line is
really badass - they always try and make
them I'm excited to see if they just
have a bigger roster that's all are you
really hold out on these games because
after a while it's just like I just want
to play with 23 different people as [ __ ]
well we're gonna be doing a let's play
for sure oh yeah when you finally a
[ __ ] Channel together I mean I'm not
getting my [ __ ] together man I go home I
just in corners of krylon it don't do me
it works off the crying man kind of good
but you cry too much I mean it's not
good when you gorgeous yeah pretty soon
you're gonna be the next girl cast
member and injustice while I crying you
do I mean there's only girl lesser I
locks - how you do you be a beautiful
woman for us and titties what kind of
same a vagina and a different face do
you think I should be should be um I
think I could work this face I think
Black Canary has the best face poison
ivy has the best body Catwoman has the
most appealing personality cheetahs a
girl you do when you're drunk it's like
we speak you know I'm not going to bone
the state because she looked like an
speak
same thing with cheetah I'm afraid she's
going to scratch me or something but it
kind of drunk you know you could
probably have it happen I was very
interesting choices right here mm-hmm I
like to put all these characters in
certain categories so near the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejection
County's crazy on Instagram that's me oh
yes [ __ ] Valentine's Day happy
Valentine's Day knows it I gotta go get
some strawberries and champagne make my
girls too
I'm single and don't have a Valentine so
if any of you lady subscribers would
love to contact me on Twitter or in the
ground without the greg alba just blow
it up go ahead let's talk because I
could I could use a connection today
just on FaceTime
like take it a couple messages yeah show
me your your boob first and then we'll
face that's the solution I'm kidding I
hope you have a good personality